disturbing video shows a Georgia mother
passed out on her steering wheel while
in the drive-through line at McDonald's
at the time a one-year-old boy was in
the back seat not far from a syringe
breaks my damn heart brother this is
dude I had never seen anything like that
so I have no idea on April 23rd officers
were called to a McDonald's in Marietta
Georgia about 40 minutes Northwest of
Atlanta workers there say a woman
ordered food but passed out in the
drive-through Lane
ma'am
hey marry the police man the woman later
identified as Kelsey Warren admitted to
getting high on heroin before heading to
the drive-through officials on the scene
say she struggled to stay awake during
the conversation hey marry the police
man
hey what's going on
[Music]
hey stop reaching what's going on
you're really tired
turn the car off first for me okay
can you hand me the keys real quick
give me your keys first man
video also shows officers interacting
hi
hey
smile
an officer can be heard reassuring the
boy you're gonna be your all right okay
buddy
you're gonna be all right at one point
an officer says he's never seen anything
like this and that the situation breaks
his heart it breaks my damn heart
brother this is dude I had never seen
anything like that so I have no idea
First Responders later recovered a
syringe from the car as well as some
cocaine Warren was taken into custody
and now faces multiple charges including
possession of a controlled substance and
endangering a child reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie